the talk today is really about
um
how can we
manage condo environments in an
enterprise environment or a large team
of people and sort of have like this
reproducibility aspect
to all of this so i'll be talking a lot
more about that
so yeah a little bit about myself i'm a
software developer at quansite
i really care about numerical computing
and reproducibility in general um
reproducibility became really important
to me um when i was heavily contributing
to a project mixed packages and nyx os
and and that's also really motivated a
lot of the converse store work that i've
been doing at consigt
and then on top of that i it just a
contributor to a lot of pi data
projects mainly mainly jupiter hub and
desk
and then one thing that's really helped
me kind of learn about all these
architectural components and stuff is
just playing around with the home lab at
my house and just really passionate
about
just managing some i.t stuff at home and
and just kind of learning and making all
the mistakes at home by yourself
so i just wanted to really quickly talk
about quansite because it's it's really
relevant to the development of condustor
so
i the way i think about it is quansite
is trying to make open source
sustainable and how do we sustain a
bunch of these pi data projects such as
numpy senpai
scipy and the list goes on and
we're coming up with methods on
having dedicated developers towards the
long-term maintenance of these projects
and if you're interested just definitely
check out the website and we are hiring
for all sorts of positions
so before i talk about condustor
i really just wanted to take a step back
and talk about why should we even have
development environments in the first
place
you know i think when i first started
developing i had one monolithic
environment where i just threw
everything into it
and
there were a lot of issues that i
encountered with that
on top of that
you're going to pay the price at some
point as a project becomes more popular
eventually you're going to have to
onboard new developers contributors and
tell them how to do the testing how to
run your package and if you don't
establish an environment early on
you'll pay for it later
additionally i mentioned a little bit
about the monolithic environment
problem
and
this happens because in the python
ecosystem packages update quite
frequently and things can break
on updates quite easily
and
then i think
really the thing that's the key for me
is the reproducibility aspect of it
is much more difficult when you have a
ton of packages in one environment and
the the package size becomes quite large
so now that i've kind of talked about
you know
what is an environment i kind of want to
be
general and say
there are a lot of ways to manage
environments maybe you're doing docker
containers or
you have an npm development environment
or you're using pi pi and virtual
environments and this question of like
why conda
would come up and to me it's really
really
if you look at all these features that i
have listed here i think that conda is a
real outlier
it has great support for windows linux
and mac os
especially for compiled libraries
and then having a concept of isolated
environments i'd like to
point out maybe if you're using like app
or
yum in the ubuntu debian or rail area
those are really
dedicated environments for that are
system-wide
the other thing is programming language
agnostic packaging
i think of like pi pi is really great in
python
but it's really python specific
same as with r
you'll have like the crayon package
manager and we're really really looking
for
a general package manager that can solve
c plus plus issues to our issues to
python issues
additionally
really because of the target audience we
need strong adoption of the package
manager in the scientific community
and
then the final bit that is really
important to me
is that the compiled libraries are not
vendored so if you deal with um
wheels on pipeline
you'll notice that like numpy will ship
with open boss already
inside of it but it's pinned to a
specific open boss version
and if you say grab another library that
needs open boss and a wheel through
pie pie they'll actually have to vendor
in open boss themselves unless you
compile it
as
yeah so
you just really run into these issues
that conda has actually solved quite
nicely
with being able to link to a central
open boss version or a fast fourier
transform library
so i hope this has kind of addressed you
know why conduct
but then
you'll be like great i have conda i'm
using it for managing environments
um i have this environment.yaml file and
anytime i need another developer to work
on it
i'll just hand them the environment.yaml
file something like that
well
we were developing at quansite we're
developing something called qhub which
is a sort of like auto scaling open
source data science environment
and
that works on all the clouds and one of
the big things that we ran into
was
you really can't just have
environment.yml files for managing
environments and have multiple users
able to
easily change them so a great example
as we've also worked for
clients is that
users want packages now so a user might
say i need numpy installed
you know
install it for me now and then
on the other side there's it that's
responsible for adding numpy to that
environment
and because of
because of reasons such as it might have
licensing constraints or
they might have some rules on what
specific versions that can be installed
or vulnerability scanning
after they've gone through the whole
approval process then they had to build
a docker image and then maybe
start the service up running with the
new docker image
and
really both sides are quite frustrated
in this this equation
and condustor our goal is to make it so
that we can sort of be the middleman
between these two and and make it really
easy to install packages environments
and also
vet them as well and
have certain policies
another thing that's really important is
that
if users are able to just create these
environment.yaml files
sometimes they'll get lazy and maybe
they'll add a new package without
actually adding it to the
environment.yaml
maybe they won't pin the specific
version
that they used
and you really lose a lot of the
reproducibility aspect of that so we
needed something that allowed users to
create new environments but at the same
time get that reproducibility
bit and have a unique
unique key for each environment that was
created
so i hope i'm like giving a really you
know a broad overview on the
frustrations that we had with really
conda m install is not enough we need we
need management around that especially
in large groups
so what is condo store
i'm about to give a demo but it is
is something for doing management of
environments
it also does builds and then it serves
the environments so how does it manage
them it provides a web ui that i'll show
i won't be showing but there is a full
rest api behind all of the environment
operations so you could automate this in
ci or you know whatever
service you're thinking of
and it also watches the file system on
specific paths that you specify to auto
update environments
and then finally we're working on a
jupiter lab extension
that will allow you to modify
your content environments inside of
jupiter lab but also get all this
reproducibility and and build parts that
i'm talking about
it also importantly for enterprise
environments
builds conda environments in a scalable
manner so it can theoretically
build in environments at the same time
just depending on the number of workers
that you have
and then finally it serves these
environments via a file system
lock files tar balls and a docker
registry which i'll show in a little bit
and all of this stuff is encapsulated in
a full role-based access
system which allows you to have default
permissions for unauthenticated users
have different name spaces that certain
people can work in and i'll show that in
a second a little bit more
and then i'll also be showing the
jupiter lab ui
before i show that i just want to say
really quick all of this is
you can easily try this out yourself you
just have to clone the conda store
repository go into the docker example
and then docker compose up and these
services will be up and running
so let me just show this really quick
so here is just the
base
conda store ui that you launch into
one thing you can see is here i have
some environments that are already
pre-populated
some things you'll see here a quansite
data science environment
and
inside of this data science environment
we have built a
let's say append environment.yaml file
that has all of the package dependencies
written down
we also have a lock file if anybody here
has seen condo lock
it's
it allows you to install a content
environment without having to do the
solve stage
which can really alleviate a lot of the
memory issues you have it's also a very
compact representation of your
environment you also see it has like a
shaw actually this is an md5 hash
of the package so you have a you
basically have a really strong guarantee
that your environment is the same
so that's the first and then the second
build artifact additionally we have a
conda pack
so if anybody here has
seen this before condo pack is a way to
tarball
up a condo environment and ship it over
just regularly send it and then extract
it on the other side there's a little
command you have to run to rewrite some
of the paths
but this provides just yet another
mechanism for sharing
the conda environment
and then finally we have docker
i'll just demonstrate this really quick
so
if i just open up
a terminal
i can
just demonstrate that this actually
implements a full docker registry which
works really nicely with kubernetes as
well
so if i do local right now i'm just
running this on localhost 5000
coinside data science
um
and that one i'm not showing that it
didn't pull because i pulled that one
before
so let's do one that hasn't been pulled
before we have default pi data which i
definitely haven't done
so it was unable to find it and then
what it's about to do
um actually this one didn't have the
docker image built let's do prod web dev
so here we can see it started
downloading all of the docker layers and
then as soon as this is done
we'll be in a docker image but the nice
thing here is we have
you'll see really soon that if we
specify a an environment so here is our
environment.yaml we have one of the
packages the regular spec that we're
used to but it automatically builds all
these different build assets so that we
can easily
let's say somebody's on their laptop and
they want to recreate the environment
they can just conda install the walk
file but if they're in a kubernetes
environment they might want the docker
file
there's another
key aspect to this and that is i'll just
show
one that i
know gives an interesting use case here
so we have the ability to have multiple
builds for a given environment and
changes over time
and what this would allow you to do is
that if you have multiple completed
builds you can actually do a rollback if
one of the environments
that you created didn't work out
so that's a one of the features that
converse store really enables is easily
switching between um builds the other
thing is that every single build has a
unique
build key associated with it
so if we just go here to
this build
and look down here
you can see that there's a unique key
assigned to every build
and this allows this reproducibility
aspect so if you do need to run an
environment
say 10 years from now
you have this really nice way of always
addressing the same build and then
running that docker image
down the road along with the tarball and
the condo lock as well however i will
point out that the condo lock
probably won't work down the road
because of
how condo channels work and that the
packages may no longer exist at that
point in time
additionally
you can see the full logs of the conda
the build that actually took place
so really quick how would a user create
a new environment so you just click
create environment you can drag and drop
new environments in here the other thing
too um
we can do this and then
flask
and then we see that it was added and as
soon as it was added we already see that
a build was queued and very soon
we'll see that it's actually building
so you can see how it has it will
automatically start to build these
environments
other things that i wanted to point out
was that
it also builds these environments on the
file system
so i mentioned a little bit about having
a jupiter lab extension for installing
conda environments
but the big benefit here is that you can
see that it's automatically added
via content in b kernels
and we can for instance play with this
is the data science environment that was
just created
so
if we look at data science
we will see
we have
numpy installed
so we can import numpy but if we import
number
that doesn't exist and we can then
quickly trigger a new build by just
editing this
and adding number
the other thing that you'll notice with
this though too
is that we keep track of all of our
previous builds so we have a nice way
of keeping track of our environments
over time as well
i mentioned a little bit about
how there is role-based access
behind all of this so right now i'm
currently authenticated and the way i
have this user authenticated is you can
see all environments
but let's suppose that i log out
you'll see that as soon as i log out
not all the environments are available
to me and that's because by default
the default namespace is read only
and then there are abilities that as
soon as you log in this is going
integrations with jupiterhub for
authentication
and as soon as you're logged in you now
get to see all of the namespaces so
there's there's really rich controls on
environments how they're created and
deleted
so i know that was a really fast um
walkthrough of a lot of the things in
condo store but i just want to make sure
i
hit on all those features there
and i may be cutting this a little bit
short with the full presentation if
there are time limits
so i wanted to talk really quickly about
how does condestor actually do the
builds
so we have a sort of environment
that's kind of just a pointer to
whatever the current
build is for that given environment
and then we have a bunch of successive
builds that are tied to environment.yaml
files
and you'll notice that you can have
multiple builds for the same
specification
and this is because
if you have an environment.yaml that's
not pinned down
it could happen that numpy comes up with
a newer version and if you do another
um another build you'll actually get a
newer version of numpy in in the next
build so
it's important to keep track of all the
different versions through time
so here i just wanted to hit on some of
the the pain points that conjustor is
really aiming to solve here
so the first one that i mentioned a
little bit before was it and user
friction this is something we
saw over and over when working with
clients
and
that is that all of our end users maybe
data scientists or
just regular developers they they need a
given package and it's really hard to
understand why it can't have that
package
available
now
and then on the other side when you get
to see the it's perspective you realize
like the complexity behind updating
environments
and
there's a lot of method to the madness
on you know why it takes such a long
time and really both sides are really
frustrated with the process
so the things that i i really think that
condustor can bring here is that it has
the rich rbac controls that will allow
it to have like dedicated read-only
environments that users can't touch
but at the same time allowing users to
have their own playground environments
but still have restrictions on you can
only have you know these sorts of
packages you can only install from this
dedicated artifactory channel
all of these constraints that it might
want to limit on their users
um yeah and then i mentioned here the
ability to enforce constraints
another key issue that i just wanted to
make sure that i i touched on here was
the ability to productionize
environments
so very often we'd see
some users just developing on jupiter
lab
they come up with this awesome notebook
that solves some
problem but the issue is that they need
this to be run every week for the next
five years
and it needs to be run on a regular
basis well as soon as they have that
notebook in that environment they really
kind of just hand it off to it and say
you know it's your job to make sure this
runs
forever essentially
and
that's a really tough problem and i
think one of the key issues there
is that we don't have a way to
reproducibly identify the environment
that the notebook was developed in and
somehow mirror that when we're running
that
on a workflow on a regular basis
so how condos store helps this is that
every build is uniquely accessible it's
available as a condo pack docker image
lock file
pendiaml
i i have ideas where i'd really like to
start producing isos and also
for the hpc community
it's really escaping me right now but
their their packaging format i'd really
like to produce singularity containers
as well there's really no reason we
couldn't do that
um like i mentioned all the builds
output many different forms
um
additionally all environments are
artifact
all artifacts are put in s3
and this is a really important thing to
have affordable storage and also just a
really easy way to back up
all of the
environments and builds that were
created
and then finally anybody that's ever
done a conda update
maybe many times has found a time when
you do a condo update and it gets an
inconsistent solve
and you run into issues there so condo
store actually does a complete new
install every single time
and it creates a so kind of sacrifices a
little bit of space
for that really reproducible
reproducible aspect there
and then this is a feature that i really
care about that i wanted to at least
show
i got really motivated and mixed there
is a project called mixery
and it is kind of what i would call an
on-the-fly docker container builder
and i was determined to build this for
conda
so
i already showed here how i pulled an
existing image but let's do a docker run
minus it
so we'll contact your same docker
registry but i have a
special conda store dynamic and anything
after this it will build a docker image
with those packages installed
so maybe i want python
less than
uh less than
3.9
i went numpy and then i went flask
installed
so you'll notice really quickly i ran
this and
it doesn't yet have the docker image
because it doesn't really exist and if
we check really quickly on here
and we refresh we'll see that there's
automatically an environment being built
and it's configurable so you can make
this hidden so users don't see it
but my main point here is that this
allows in a kubernetes environment
we can kind of stop creating these like
i mean everybody's had to write docker
files before that seem overly repetitive
and this would allow on-the-fly docker
environments with arbitrary conda
packages installed
you can also configure the the base
image that's used
but i think for really light things that
don't really have any secret sauce in
them i'll give an example we're trying
to run a jupiter hub
server in kubernetes well jupiter hub is
just a python package that you can
install with conda
and then you just mount in the
configuration but there's really nothing
secret to that container
and and i don't believe that we should
we should be having to build these
custom images with just single or
multiple packages installed in them
um so this is something that
is one of the reasons why i implemented
a
docker registry inside of condo store is
so that we can do these sorts of tricks
where docker images don't exist
yeah so you can actually see the build
just completed it built a docker image
and then it
started pulling it in
again i don't think this is really
something that's used heavily but i i
think this has a really interesting use
case in the future so here we see
i did python less than three nine
and if we type python we see that we get
three eight
there
okay
and then finally just wanted to talk
about the road map
so one of um things after talking to the
condo forge folks is that it would be
really nice to have a
remote conda environment solver api
and most of the issues when you do a
conda install revolve around the solve
step and
memory issues typically on laptops and
and it could be really nice if we had a
service um publicly that would be able
to
do these solves that said condo store is
fully open source and you can run it on
your own but we thought it would be nice
to offer a service like a remote condor
solver api at some point i also
mentioned this jupiter lab ui
which has been important to us because i
i don't think the conda store ui should
be the way that people interact
with it i think it should just be the
normal jupiter lab flow and with that
we're trying to use
something that quanstat folks have
developed called gator and extend that
additionally i'd like to
integrate with jupiter enterprise
gateway
anyone familiar with that project it
allows you to
kind of separate the kernel from the
jupyter lab server
and i think that condo store and
building docker images could be really
interesting in this use case
additionally
i mentioned a little bit before that i'd
like to build also additional
environment formats singularity and vm
iso's
this isn't immediately on the road like
isn't going to immediately be done but
i'd like to get this to done soon and
that i think it has a lot of value to
the hpc community
and then finally
we're working on an integration with our
auto scaling open source data science
environment q hub
to kind of be one of the first
trials of fully integrating conda store
so with that i know i spoke really
quickly
probably should have put less on the
slides but i really appreciate y'all's
time if there are any questions
please please ask
thank you chris for the talk and i see
there are some other questions in the
chat so the question is what if i need a
package that requires manual compilation
like tensorflow on arm arm machine
requires manual compile
what should we do then
yeah so for manual compilation so right
now it's just doing conda installs from
packages that are available on
different channels maybe i'd recommend
there
with the build process that once you do
your custom build for that given
architecture that you upload it to a
kind of a private condo channel and and
then condo store could then use
that given custom build that you made
i hope that helps answer that but i'm
trying to conduct story is trying to be
more around environment management and
on the individual package level side
we're trying to defer to anaconda teams
and uh there's another one the quan
stack folks have been working on and
kind of want to defer to them to really
handle the the packaging issues
all right uh
the next question is why is the conda
store jupiter lab extension archive
i imagine that so you should just look
in
okay why is it archived right so
originally we were looking at building
our own jupiter lab extension
and then we found the work that clone
stack has been doing on something called
gator which if you haven't tried it out
i already encourage you to it works
locally with conda or mamba
for the environments
and we instead of building another
environment management tool in jupiter
lab we really want to work with them and
kind of to to help build the tool that
people use to manage environments in
jupiter lab on
we have another question which is why
what is used as the base image for the
docker builds
so right now the base image is an alpine
glibc image
and that's configurable in condo store
it uses traitlets underneath the covers
so you can really specify any docker
image that you're able to pull
so if you have a private one you'll need
to put in your docker credentials maybe
do a docker login beforehand but it
should be able to pull it just fine
the last question is uh does this play
nicely with mamba too
yeah we actually use mamba um underneath
the cover so um klonsite is actually
doing some work right now to
integrate uh all of the mamba solve
pieces into conda to give it just as
fast environment solves
but at the moment
the
mamba solves um solved much faster i i'd
even i'd claim maybe five times faster
or so that i'm seeing
and the memory usage is also
significantly lower so yeah we're yes
we're using mamba long answer for that
all right thank you
uh i think this brings us to the end of
the time and uh
thank you chris uh sir thank you chris
for going to this presentation and this
seems like a good thing to use and i
think i'm gonna check it out like i've
been using notebooks for quite a while
yeah awesome
well thank you